what is it like to be a world-renowned
artist but be forced to hire your
artwork from the public today we're
meeting a man who's risking it all to
preserve the tradition of Japanese
tattooing for future generations for
thousands of years
tattoos have been part of cultures all
over the world I'm Chelsey Pineda and
I'm Sydney Cramer together
we're on a journey to discover the
history traditions and future of body
art this is an expedition
we're here in Japan to learn about the
art of traditional Japanese tattooing
[Music]
and we're meeting with Choshu Horacio a
tattoo artist known for preserving the
art of ciborium hora Kazu is legendary
in the tattooing community but in public
he's forced to cover his ink under long
sleeves because tattoos are still widely
condemned in Japanese culture so she
wanted a mortgage cut into kind of a
patent combat zone it's anesthesia only
in his studio can he reveal his body art
and tattoo videos for our TV Tokyo
versus de bordo velocity Kahuna no my
students against wha hey Makoto system
the cinnamon or thirsty hora Kazu has
been practicing too worried for 14 years
the ancient tattoo method uses a long
rod that plunges ink into the skin with
sharp needles for a tattoo client Tabora
can be a way to connect to the past but
horror causes clients must hide his
artwork from the world
we met with Tatsuya anthropologist Lars
krutov who explain the origins of
Japan's tattoo taboos making tattoos via
hand is a nod to tradition and it
expresses great cultural pride and for
the tattoo client it is a way to
experience something that is both
ancient and spiritual perhaps the
earliest written record of tattooing in
Japan dates to 400 AD when it has been
described that a man tried to overthrow
the Emperor and as a form of punishment
he was given a tattoo near his eye and
for the next 1,000 years tattooing was
associated with criminal acts and it's
been sort of widely stereotyped as
something extremely negative today
people from all walks of life received
tattoos in Japan there are still a lot
of stigmas attached to them and if you
go to a public beach or even a bathhouse
people with tattoos are not admitted
whatsoever the stigma of tattoos in
modern Japan belies a rich cultural
history long after tattooing was used as
a form of punishment it was popularized
in the Edo period between the years 1603
and 1868 during this time stories were
told of anti-authoritarian heroes who
wore body art as spiritual armor
these stories resonated with the people
of Japan who are looking for ways to
express themselves in a rigid class
system inspired by the folklore everyday
heroes like firefighters began to use
tattoos as our own form of protection
[Music]
sensing the subversive nature against
the class system hidden in the tattoos
the Emperor's government issued bans
against them driving the art form
underground Choshu hora Kazu has chosen
to honor history's forgotten fighters by
continuing to practice to bori despite
the stigma
Nihon did though skills to do this
watashi no koto wa tottemo daisuki ah
bunka of Cocoon so while Hockaday figure
they give it all this in the studio hora
causes hidden canvases are free to be on
full display
[Music]
[Music]
he offered us a temporary freehand
tattoo and we couldn't resist getting
inked by the master
even if it was just a marker
[Music]
that's what I was thinking
[Music]
[Music]
Watterson dr. Ludmilla psycho no quieres
kono subarashii nihongo dentist okay so
she had a 54 data category so she was
little
there are signs that tattoos are
becoming less stigmatized in modern
Japan and it's possible that eventually
for Acacio and his clients won't have to
hide their true selves from the world
until then the deep emotional and
historical significance of de bourree is
enough to warrant a life of secrecy for
hora Kazu the preservation of traditions
is worth every personal sacrifice
[Music]
next time on ink expedition rare meeting
fat fish
who is famous for her intricate Celtic
knot tattoos